so often times when a person comes to me
and i have several
i call this wisdom counseling i have
several methods depending on the person
but let's say a person comes to me and
says hey rabbi what's this all about
give me the big picture before i sign up
so i'll say all right i want you to give
me a theory of the good
in your life every part of your life
your romantic connections
children work and a relatively precise
uh as detailed as possible
what you would like what you would think
what would you feel what you would say
how others would react to you as
as precise as possible i call this a
relatively precise
vision for your life if you could live
optimally what would it be like
so it's not that i say you have to i
want them to say
i have to i'm not i said i'm not telling
you do anything
but if you have a relatively detailed
vision that you know yourself would lead
to a life
a flourishing life the greek idea of
eudaimonia
then the question is what's the gap
and how do we close the gap and if you
want to close the gap i'll help you
what is the percentage of people that
come to you who hold that vision for
themselves versus
the individual who comes in and says
look on paper everything's good
got a good job drive a nice car i've got
a nice family
sometimes my kids hate me but i can pay
the mortgage and i go to this job it's
fine
but there's something missing in my life
i don't know what it is but i feel this
sense of of calling to
something greater but i have no
connection to what that might be
it's not an uncommon question that i get
so then i have to say uh like are you
signing up
it's like it's like my jiu jitsu club
are you signing up
because is it is this a one-off
flirtation yeah it is if it's a one-off
that's fine
i'll give you a couple of ideas and but
if you're signing up which means
you might come to my wisdom classes on
on wednesday nights come to one thing or
another
um then i would start with can we break
this down
so you're not getting along with your
kids i need to know more about that
because sometimes people suffer
because they're not nourished by their
interpersonal relationships and let's
say for example their estrangement with
their child is killing them
or i have a nice job but some level they
hate the job
and they're done with it so when a
person says i'm basically doing
okay but something's missing the first
thing i have to do
is find out exactly what's happening in
each of these areas
and see if something's missing in there
typically something is
typically they don't know how to process
with the spouse
they don't know how to process with the
kids their work life has
you know reached its maximum potential
for for meaning
so once we start examining things that i
the sense of something's missing
let's get to what exactly is missing now
let's say a person
hardly ever but a person reports
relationships are good
i'm really regulated we're processing
and i hear all that i say okay so it's
depth
if you feel something missing if you
feel the abyss within we call that depth
and that takes hard work
and then what is the process going
forward of getting somebody more
connected to that
oh to depth so we're like we're jumping
to the end though right yeah yeah we're
talking like i'm going to ap course
okay man so we're going all right to the
brown belt black belt level most people
are happy with the blue belt
okay so but if i got that person who
says i'm not stop until i get my higher
belt
um so i use the approach of young
carly young not in any kind of
doctrinaire
sense but ultimately
in the realm of the soul it's a a
meaning
driven part of the inner life it can be
uh addressed through religion philosophy
art um i think religion falsely and art
come out of the soul
and they think the soul is the aspect of
the human being that actually um
apprehends symbols myths
poetry music at the deep level so we'll
we'll call the soul a fact minimally a
faculty of knowing
uh james hillman is one of my favorite
people to study here he says the soul is
where events become experiences
where things are taken down so first of
all
um the soul is always at work but
sometimes unnourished
unexpressed and from young's perspective
that's why you suffer
you suffer because you haven't found a
way to let the concerns of the soul
manifest into your life so unlike freud
where he
um you know i thought it was because of
repression
uh jung thought it was more uh
the inability for a person to articulate
the concerns of the soul into their
lives
and then just come some time for
investigation um
i gotta find out what their what what
medium they connect to
immediately music movies
books poetry you know and uh
now and then i get a person where the
marriage is in trouble because the wife
says
uh i can't be married to a superficial
man
so you know we've done it for 30 years
and now i'm done
right she's spending weekends in sedona
he says i don't know what she's talking
about
so it's an external pressure yes and he
said
what is this thing and you know
accountant lawyer
and i you know like and my marriage is
at stake what do i do rabbi
i said okay so i tried to figure out
like where's the opening here
so i finally he he's a guy a little bit
older than i am i'm 66 about 70.
and uh music rock music
i said okay i said are you aware that
the beatles changed
from 62 to 66 you know that happened
right
um he said yes i want you to go back and
listen to the beatles after 65
abbey road rubber soul i want you to
tell me what happened
okay so um
he called me and said okay i found a
better therapist
that's hilarious i know huh but he got
scared
he got scared because listen to abby
road what's happening there listen to
rubber soul listen to revolver
right you know listen what happened to
those guys sergeant pepper
sergeant pepper exactly and and then i
said and
tell me what happened to them so
i think he wanted to talk about his
mother you know like right right right
yeah so yeah it was a it was a spiritual
awakening that they had they went on a
journey
and they became more expanded
individuals and in turn
more fully expressed artists right yeah
the beatles yes
yeah and and the thing is i have a lot
of compassion for that guy who comes to
you
i think that's the predicament of the
typical
modern human because we live in a time
that i would define as a crisis
of consciousness and spiritual
connection right
we're in this sort of uh competitive
predatory relationship with other people
with ourselves with the world
it's a zero-sum approach to basically
everything we're materialists seeking
answers
in ego status money power
consumption accumulation and
it's also a culture in which it's
considered a lower order
naivete to seek reconciliation or
answers in
the mystical and the unknown right it's
almost
perceived as a weakness in
this age of science and yet when you
look around you see
depression rates and suicide rates at
unprecedented levels
we're seeing this breakdown in our
ability to civilly communicate with each
other
the seeds of social destruction have
been sown right and
from my perspective the only way for the
only salvation
is in spiritual practice and learning to
more deeply connect with who we are to
find our innate humanity that allows us
to connect to others
and live more symbiotically you know on
this planet that supports
us and yet i despair at times because
i don't see that as a cultural priority
[Music]
[Music]
you